[Music]
and now one of the most respected
investors in America is going to tell
you about his
secrets Warren Buffett it's the sound of
money the second richest man in America
he's estimated to be worth about 62
billion and makes him the richest man in
the
world you know Buffett is not exactly
what you might
expect even though he's in the money
business he doesn't even own a
calculator or a computer he takes the
Long View and it's made him billions
many billions
maybe you could beat the house but I
don't think you could beat Warren
Buffett Buffett filed his first tax
return at 13 years old but he's no
average billionaire Tom no he certainly
isn't Mt he's a $44 billion Average
Joe Warren Buffett has an approach that
doesn't make him very popular with his
fellow
billionaires Warren Buffett the boy from
Nebraska who grew up to become the
wizard of Omaha what was it about him
that allowed him to become the richest
man in the world how did he do
[Music]
it 70 years ago I was in high school
almost a third as long as the country
has been
around and when I was in high school I
really only had two things on my mind
girls and cars car s and and it wasn't
doing very well with girls so we'll talk
about cars but let's just imagine that
when we finish I'm going to let each one
of you pick out the car of your choice
sounds good doesn't it uh pick it out
any color you name it it'll be tied up
with a bow and it'll be at your house
tomorrow and you say well what's the
catch and the catch is that is the only
car you're going to get in your
lifetime now what are you going to do
knowing that that's the only car you're
ever going to have and you love that car
you're going to take care of it like you
cannot believe now what I'd like to
suggest you're not going to get only one
car in your lifetime but you're going to
get one body and one mind and that's all
you're going to get and that body and
mind feels terrific now but it has to
last your lifetime
I'm on the way to the office it's a all
of a five minute
drive been doing it
uh for
years one of the good things about this
5minute drive is that uh on the way
there's a McDonald's so I'll pick up
something good morning thank you for
choosing McDonald's go ahead and order
whenever you're ready h sausage McMuffin
with egg and
cheese anything else that's it thank you
and I tell my wife as I shave in the
morning I say either 261 295 or 317 and
she puts that amount in a little cup by
me here and that determines which of
three breakfasts I get 29 okay
295 there's how you doing sir hey great
you're on Ted camera I see hello
everybody when I'm not feeling quite so
prosperous I might go with a 261 which
is two sausage patties and then I put
them together and uh pour myself a
Coke Hi how are you
good 317 is a bacon egg and cheese
biscuit but the Market's down this
morning so I think I'll pass up to 317
and go with the
I like
numbers started before I can
remember it just felt good working with
numbers I was always playing around with
numbers in one way or another and it was
fun to have a bunch of guys over and
have them betting on which Marvel would
reach the drain
first I had a lot of energy as I I was
inquisitive and I was the youngest one
always in the class cuz I'd ski I've
always been
[Music]
competitive I like to read more than
most kids I really like to read a
lot my aunt Edie gave me a copy of the
World Almanac and that was Heaven to me
and I can still tell you that Al
population was 214,000 and6 in
1930 some numbers just kind of stick
with
you and very early probably when I was
seven or so I took the book out of the
venson library called a th000 ways to
make
$1,000 and one of the ways in this book
was having Penny weighing
machines and I sat and calculated how
much it would cost to buy the first
weighing machine and then how long it
would take for the profit for that one
to buy another one and I would sit there
and create these compound interest
tables to figure out how long it would
take me to have a weighing machine for
every person in the
world I had everybody body in the
country weighing themselves 10 times a
day and me just sitting there like John
de rockerfeller weighing
machines the allowance when I was a
little boy was a nickel a week but I
like the idea of having a little more
than a nickel a week to work with and I
went into business very
early I started selling Coca-Cola door
to door I sold gum door to door so
Saturday in post Liberty magazine Ladies
Home Journal you name
it
I think I enjoyed the game almost right
from the
start but I like being My Own Boss
that's one thing I like about delivering
papers I got arranged the route I wanted
nobody was bothering me at 5: or 600 in
the
morning I was delivering 500 papers a
day and I made a penny of paper but in
terms of compounding is that Penny sht
into something
else
Einstein is reputed have said that
compound interest is the eighth wonder
of the world or something like that and
it goes back to that story you probably
learned when you were in grade school
where somebody did something for the
king and the King said what can I do for
you and he said well let's take a chess
board and put one Colonel of wheat on
the first square and then doubled it on
the second and doubled it on the third
and the King agreed to it and by the
time he figured out what 2 to the 64th
amounted to he was giving away the
entire Kingdom so it's a pretty simple
concept but over time it accomplishes
extraordinary
things Berkshire is an amazing company
it's fourth largest company in the
Fortune 500 he is the only person who is
Ever from
scratch built a company that is in the
top 10 of the Fortune
500 thank you well Berkshire is a
holding company of sorts it owns a large
number of separate businesses that
operate independently of each other and
to a great extent from the parent
company Berkshire
haway what my favorite so we're get more
from you in a we have maybe 70 maybe 80
businesses and we ask them to behave in
a way that doesn't hurt our reputation
at Berkshire hathway but they run their
own
lives other people do most of the
decorating of the office so various
things come
in originally when I moved in in
1962 you can see this I went down to the
South alaha library and I think for a
dollar I got seven copies of old New
York Times from from Big times like the
Panic of 1907 this is one 1929 obviously
but I wanted to put on the walls days of
extreme panic in Wall Street just as a
reminder that anything could happened in
this world I mean it uh it's instructive
art you can call
it
I was born in 1930 here in alont
arbraska during the stock market
crash well my dad lost his job in 19 31
a year after I was
born he was a stock salesman and he had
what little savings he had in the bank
and so he started his own company he
worked right through the
depression
he had an investment company and as an
adult when I looked back I thought wow
did that ever take a lot of
nerve sometimes we'd go down there on
Sunday and we could play with the adding
machine my brother and I tended to play
the games together and I remember at one
point he said to me I'm going to be a
millionaire by the time I'm 30 or
something like that it was totally
outside of anything my family had
experienced but it just was unusual that
way well I was the oldest and then my
brother and then my sister and my father
would go to New York periodically to
check on businesses and stocks and
things like that and he come back he
always had a costume for each of us and
warm loved
it he was very good nature he was quiet
it was hard to tell he was a genius at
that point but um I mean who was looking
the first books I read on investment
were actually in my dad's
office pretty soon I read all the books
in the office and read some of them more
than
once my dad had various nicknames for me
he'd call me Fireball sometimes because
I'd start little
businesses he didn't care about money at
all he believed very much in having an
inner Store card and I never worry about
what other people people are thinking
about you you know just just uh if you
know why you're doing what you're doing
that's good enough I admired everything
about him to the extent that I was
absorbing lessons from him without
knowing it and the idea that all eyes
have equal value is something that all
three of his children felt since I can
remember my dad at one point ran for
congress when I was 12 or
so it was a very Republican house
household I campaigned for him my
sister's campaign for him the whole
family
[Music]
did my mother was very very bright and
she was very gregar she was a good
campaigner for my
dad she had a lot of ambition and I
think my brother Warren got a lot of his
extreme competitiveness from my mother
actually she was brilliant at math
you know I guess they still had these
things where you crank them and things
added up and she could add it in her
head faster than the machine could do it
she was absolutely amazing in
that she was very dutiful about taking
care of the kids but you didn't get the
same feeling of of love it was there but
it just it didn't come out the same way
as with my
dad in the nation the only permanent way
to Prosperity is a balanced budget
unless that goal is achieved
all postwar plans will collapse like
Hitler's Conquest you have heard
Congressman Howard LH puppet Republican
member of the House of Representatives
from Nebraska when I was about 12 or 13
we moved to Washington my family and I
was mad I was having fun in Omaha I
watched all my friends and now I moved
to a town where they were all strange
and uh so I was very very
unhappy at school I just lost
interest I took pleasure in tormenting
my
teachers at that time for example AT&T
was the stock that all teachers own for
their
retirement and I decided that it would
drive my teachers a little crazy if I
went short the stock because when you go
short of stock you're betting that it
will go down so I shorted 10 chairs of
AT&T and then brought the confirmation
to school and show these teachers that I
was shorting the stock
they found me a big pain in the neck but
they did think I knew a lot about
[Music]
stocks and then at home my mother would
have terrific
headaches and you didn't want to be
around her when she was having the
headaches and she would she would lash
out more she would never do it in
public well I think we were terrified of
her when I'd wake up in the morning I'd
listen to hear her voice I could tell by
her voice was going to be a terrible day
or not
when she got difficult the three
children fell
it when I was at the low Point sort of I
decided that I would run
away so I talked two other guys on
running away with
me we went out and we started
hitchhiking and then we got picked up by
the highway patrol and that scared the
hell out
[Music]
of it's very interesting my dad never
really gave me help about doing this but
he finally said you know he said you can
do better than this and just saying that
I mean I I felt I was letting him down
basically so in all ways he was teaching
me never taught by telling me things he
just taught by example he had unlimited
confidence in me even when I screwed up
and that takes you a long long
way the best gift I was ever given
was to have a father that I had when I
was
[Music]
born I didn't want to go to college I
was 16 when I got out of high school and
I was buying stocks I mean I actually
was having a pretty good time and I
didn't see that really was much to be
gained by going to college but my dad
kind of jollied me into
it he had a roommate who was a friend of
mine and the roommate said it just
driving him crazy because he studied all
the time when w would come in like 15
minutes before the exam and just ace his
way through
it I finished in three years because I
had enough credits then I was in a hurry
I wanted to get
out when I got out of the University of
Nebraska I applied to Harvard Business
School they told me I was to get
interviewed in a place near Chicago I
got there and uh he interviewed me for
about 10 minutes and he said forget it
you're not going to Harvard and so now
I'm thinking what do I tell my Dad yeah
this is terrible and it turned out be
the best thing ever happened to me later
that summer I was looking through a
catalog and in the catalog it had these
names of people that were teaching and
one was Graham and another was do I had
read this book by the two of them so I
wrote him a letter in mid August and I
said Dear Professor Dodd I said I
thought you guys were were dead but now
that I found out that you're alive and
teaching at Columbia I would really like
to come and he admitted me so you know
that it just shows you never can
tell a
gentleman Ben was this incredible
teacher I mean he was a natural and he
drew us all in our Wall Street
professionals they more accurate in the
shorter term term than the long-term
pokat well our studies indicate that you
have your choice between tossing coins
and taking the consensus of expert
opinion and the results are just about
the same in each
case it was like learning baseball from
a fellow who was batting
400 it really it shaped my professional
life there are two rules of investing
according to Warren and he learned this
from uh Ben Graham
rule number one never lose money rule
number two never forget rule number
one Ben Graham basically coined the term
value investing he believed in careful
scrutiny of a company's financial
statements and that if you bought value
it would eventually prove
out a few years ago so I went to Amazon
and sure enough they had this manual
there so while reliving my youth other
guys were going to Amazon probably and
uh buying old Playboys or something but
I bought old Moody manuals instead and
when I got out of school I started
selling stocks I was 20 years old at the
time and looked about 16 and acted about
12 so I was not the most impressive
salesperson anybody ever met uh but what
I would do was I I went through Page by
Page looking for possibly undervalued
stocks is this like going through an old
family album
better when I got out of business school
at
Columbia I developed pretty decent
skills in terms of business but I hadn't
really come to terms with the world
exactly what were you like around girls
back then bad I I was sort of out of the
swing of things there for a while
I went to my 60th reunion there's a girl
there I took her out one time to the
Uptown Theater in Washington and I asked
her whether she remember what movie we
saw and she said no I don't remember
that and then she said but I do remember
one thing and like an idiot I said what
was that and she said well you picked me
up in a hearse and it was true that I
owned a half interest in a hearse while
I was in high school which was not the
smoothest thing that or coolest as they
would say now the thing that you could
you could do on a
[Music]
date there were two turning points in my
life once when I came out of the womb
and once while I M Susie
basically she was the girl
yeah but it took her a little longer to
figure out I was the
boy I was going to be his youngest
sister's roommate at northwester so I
watch into their house and he was
sitting in this chair and he made some
sarcastic quip so I made one back I
thought who is this
jerk and that's how we met
yes listen Warren is smarter than you
even know his brain is going all the
time and my dad said to me now you have
to understand about him you're not going
to have discussions with him like you
would most normal people but he has a
heart of
gold he was just totally amored of her
and why not and she of
him she'd sit on his lap all the time
and he'd stroke her hair it was
softening
him Susie was really kind considerate
and she was the balancing
[Music]
Force I just got very very very lucky
but I was a lopsided person and it took
a while but she just stood there with a
a little uh watering can and just
nourished me along and and changed
[Music]
me somebody once said that the chains of
habit are too light to be felt until
they're too heavy to be
broken I had been terrified of public
speaking I couldn't do it I throw
up and I knew if I didn't cure C it then
i' never cure
it and so I saw it add in the paper for
the Dale Carnegie course which worked on
developing your ability to speak in
public and I went down there be sincere
a good smile has the same effect as a
puppy's tail when a puppy they made us
do all these crazy things to get out of
ourselves and so we stood on tables and
did all kinds of
things if I hadn't have done that my
whole life would have been
different so in my office you will not
see the degree I got from the University
of Nebraska you'll not see the Master's
Degree I got from colum University but
you'll see the little award certificate
I got from the Dale Carnegie
course as a matter of fact every week
the instructor would give a pencil to
whoever had done the most with what we'd
learned the week
before and so in the fourth or fifth
week I proposed to her mother and she
said yes and so that week I won the
pencil and I also got engaged I it was
incredible
week wedding date was kind of
interesting because I couldn't see
anything without all my glasses and I
was so nervous that I I just decided
take off my glasses and I wouldn't be
able to see all those people out
there
she was 19 when we got married and I was
21 but she was so much more mature than
I was there's no
comparison she was a better person than
I
was but when you get married it's not a
question of saying I want to put a 14%
factor in for humor and 177% for
intellect and 22% for looks it doesn't
work that way
way I knew it was the right decision and
uh and it
[Music]
was you could live anywhere in the world
why do you choose omahan I love it I you
know I was born about a mile from here
and uh you know I've never had a bad
experience in
no
Omaha and Nebraska are home to
me everything about it seems like
home it's a pace it's
relationships there's a lot of
continuity there's a lot of community
there's a lot of friendship it's a very
solid place and friendly place in which
to grow up and in which to conduct a
business when I came back to om in early
1956 I had no idea what I was going to
do but a few months after I came back
some members of the family said what
should we do with our money and I said
well I'm not going back in the business
of selling stocks but if you would like
to join me in a partnership I said I'll
be glad to do it so within a couple of
months after coming back I set up the
first
partnership
I wrote all the checks individually I
filed 11 income tax returns I took the
libery on stocks for all the different
companies I I was a oneman ban there for
six
years Juan would sit upstairs in his
little office there and uh I would bring
up the name of a company and most of the
time he knew much more than I did about
the company he'd know how many shares
were out understanding he'd know the
capitalization he'd know the earnings it
was absolutely
incredible I mean when Warren said
something it meant a heck of a lot and I
think all of us paid a lot of attention
to war when he took a definite stand on
something when I first met Warren back
in
1959 I recognized immediately that he
was a very intelligent person for the
last four or five years the stock market
has been booming along and
presumably forecasting Better Business
which is really not materialized so
maybe the stock market is really uh
correcting a previous incorrect forecast
this time rather than making a new
correct one he made a lot of money
buying thinly traded Securities that
were incredibly cheap
statistically Warren was at that time
dealing with small companies and his
Investments often were to buy a company
that you could could figure was a
discarded cigar butt but it had one more
smoke in it and he wanted to buy at the
right time to be able to benefit from
the one
smoke the first partnership started with
$15,100 I put up the1 and the other
people put up 105,000 and then at the
start of 1962 I moved to kiw Plaza and
uh by the time I moved to kiet Plaza we
had $7 million invested and fair amount
was profits
I was then renting a house I never owned
a house to that point and then two years
later I bought the house I live in today
in
[Music]
1958 we had three children Susie and
I and we had him young incidentally
which was I think a very good thing
my daughter Susie was born
here I named her Susie just like that as
soon as I looked at her she looked just
like her
[Music]
mother and uh she was a
CCH and then how he was you know this
absolute bundle of
energy which made things very difficult
for for big Susie for a
while Peter again reverted back to
Susie's personality and he was an easy
child you know I describe my childhood
is normal but who knows what normal is
people often think you know well Warren
Buffett was this famous rich guy he was
not famous and he wasn't Rich when we
were growing
up what I saw first and foremost day in
and day out was
consistency every day we'd hear the
garage door Clos in the house and then
like clockwork my dad would come in the
door I'm home and we'd all eat dinner
together which I think surprises a lot
of
[Music]
people my dad he used to rock me to
sleep at night and sing Over the Rainbow
so I have this insanely sentimental
attachment to that
song I've always had a really close
relationship with
[Music]
him I've got three very different kids
and they've got a common heart which
they got from their
mother she did most of the work by far
of bringing up the children which was
probably a good thing they have more of
her qualities than mine which is I would
I would
recommend well my mom was the biggest
part of my life growing up
even though I got disciplined on a
regular basis and she was usually the
one doing it she was still my best
friend she was somebody who would help
anybody I mean whether she knew him or
didn't know him or maybe even didn't
agree with them she would still help
them she was incredibly empathetic and
she was interested in every person
individually she never cared about money
or business at
all I mean he would go around saying I'm
going to be the richest man in the world
and I think well it's like somebody says
I play music and I'm gonna be Mozart I
don't know how does anyone
know how does anyone know you know so
that was okay I don't really care about
that I would say that Susie LED Warren
toward changing his political views he
grew up as a young Republican his his
father was a republican Congressman but
Susie saw things in different ways she
was the
[Music]
Catalyst do we want
now when the children were growing up I
was very involved in civil rights I was
immersed in it and I think that's what
made Warren a Democrat he would go with
me to hear
speakers I remember that speech that
Martin Luther King gave that was one of
the most inspiring speeches I I've ever
heard I come to say to you this took me
right out of my seat my wife was with me
and we both had the same experience not
it was interesting he in that speech he
talked about truth Forever on the
scaffold wrong forever on the
throne but that scaffold sways the
future well he was going to be dead in 6
months but that scaffold did sway the
future my wife was more active than I
was but I was 100% with her mentally I
was just working a little more on my own
uh
Investments but it didn't make a
difference what we're going to do with
the money after we made it I thought I
would pile it up over the years then she
would UNP it in terms of running a one
very large
foundation and I was particularly good
at compounding money and therefore
society would benefit by
[Music]
waiting I was genetically blessed with a
certain wiring that's very useful in a
highly developed market system where
there's lots of chips on the table and
you know I happen to be good at that
game Ted Williams wrote a book called
the science of hitting and in it he had
a picture of himself at bat and the
strike zone broken into I think 77
squares and he said if he waited for the
pitch that was really in a sweet spot he
would bat 400 and if he had to swing at
something on the lower corner he would
probably bat
235 and in investing I'm in a no called
strike business which is the best
business you can be in I can look at a
thousand different companies and I don't
have to be right on every one of them or
even 50 of
them so I can pick the ball I want to
hit and the trick in investing is just
to sit there and watch Pitch after pitch
go by and wait for the one right in your
sweet spot and if people are yelling
swing you bum ignore them
there's a Temptation for people to act
far too frequently in stocks simply
because they're so
liquid over the years you develop a lot
of filters and I do know what I call my
circle of confidence so I I I stay
within that Circle and I don't worry
about things that are outside that
Circle defining what your game is where
you're going to have an edge is
enormously
important
I bought the first shares of birkshire
in 1962 and it was a northern textile
business destined to become extinct
eventually and uh it was a statistically
cheap stock in a terrible
business birkshire pathway was closing
Mills and as they closed Mills it would
free up some capital and then they would
repurchase shares so I bought some stock
with the idea that there would be
another tender offer at some point and
we would sell the stock at a modest
profit and at one point the management
asked me at what price we would tender
our stock and I said
$11.50 and the tender offer came out of
few months later and uh it was at $111
and 38 was eighth of a point
cheaper and that made me very mad so I
just started buying more
stock I just felt that
had been double crossed by the
management and and in May of 1965 it
bought enough so we controlled the
company and we changed the
management that was a pretty silly way
to behave as Warren has recounted in
retrospect one of the reasons Warren
successful is he's brutal in appraising
his own past he wants to identify
misthink and avoid them in the future
but it was an accident that he chose
birer haway if the chairman hadn't tried
to cheat him out of an eighth there
wouldn't have been any Buffett Dash
birer ha away
history if you're emotional about
investment you're not going to do well
you may have all these feelings about
the stock the stock has no feelings
about
you looking back it's interesting that
tender offer I didn't realize it but it
happened about five days after my dad
had died and I whether that had affected
me or not I don't
[Music]
know do you remember your last
conversation with your father yeah but I
I don't want to talk about
it I think it just sobered him and hurt
him
[Music]
but waren soldiers
on
both Warren and I could look at our
fathers and see what they did right and
what they did wrong Warren's father was
a real oldfashioned right-wing
ideologue and his father was so intense
about it that Warren just decided that
was a mistake it caged up your head to
be that much of an ideologue so he loved
his father but he didn't want to become
that much of a True Believer in in
anything
[Music]
my politics became more overt after my
dad
died civil rights changed my views you
know in 1776 Thomas Jefferson wrote all
men are created equal and then when they
wrote the Constitution they all of a
sudden decided that no it was just
three- fifths of a person if you were
black I mean that struck me as kind of
crazy I was talking to him one day about
some racial issue and he said to me wait
till women discover they're the slaves
of the
world now how many men were cognizant of
that and even women
then the initial examples really my
mother she came from a generation where
the main function of the wife was to
help her husband in in the job and my
sisters are fully as smart as I am they
got better personalities than and I have
but they got the message a million
different ways that their future was
limited and I got the message that the
sky is the limit and it wasn't due to a
lack of Love or anything of the sort
it's just it was the
culture on the other hand you can look
to the flip side of that and say it's
quite encouraging because if you look at
what this country accomplished only
using half of its Talent you know just
think of the potential for the future
I'm enormously bullish on America over
the future and part of the reason is
that we by a some rather stupid
positions essentially put half our
talent on the
sidelines Warren is probably the most
rational person I've ever met Charlie
muger would be a close rival and Charlie
became a man that Warren depended on
heavily and I think his first
experiences in the discarded cigar butt
era convinced him that it was not
exactly where he wanted to be he'd made
so much money for so long doing what
he'd been taught by Ben Graham which to
buy these very cheap stocks if they were
cheap enough he didn't care it was a
lousy company in lousy management he he
knew he was going to make money anyway
just because of the
cheapness Charlie Munger has had a big
impact on me in moving me toward looking
for wonderful companies at fair prices
rather than fair companies at wonderful
prices and that was enormously important
because it enabled berer to scale up in
a way that would have been impossible to
do
otherwise yep what are the key
indicators you look for within companies
before making an investment well I look
for something that does give them a
motor
rod we have a company called se's candy
out on the west coast se's candy is box
chocolates if you give a box of se's
chocolates to your girlfriend of the
first date and she kisses
you we own you you know I we we can
raise the price tomorrow you'll buy the
same box you're not going to fool around
with success so the key there is the
response you do not want to go home on
Valentine's Day and say to your wife or
your sweetheart preferably they're the
same person you don't say here honey I
took the low bid it doesn't work price
is to a degree is immaterial if you've
got a economic Castle people are going
to come and want to take that castle
away from you and you better have a
strong Mo you have a knight in the
castle that knows what he's
doing you're not buying an asset you're
buying a name you're buying a brand
you're buying a real franchise here and
Charlie was more responsible for that
than
anybody we were medal Partners right
from the moment we
met I want to know going back 50 years
what it was like when you first met
Warren well I thought he was a
prodigy and I got a lot of criticism my
wife said why are you paying such
enormous respect to that young man with
a crew cut who won't eat
vegetables he's ungodly Mark he's got a
much broader intellect than I do and
he's magnificent at being able to
condense important ideas into just a
very few words if you're not interested
in the economic scene right now you're
mentally dead Charlie has no ta all
right let's talk a little bit about
Bankers Charlie on Friday compared them
to heroin addicts yeah well that's
colorful Charlie but I would not have
chosen that I once wrote of him that
when they handed out humility he didn't
get his fair share the ideal way to run
a headquarters is to have one man
preferably over 80 sitting in an office
by
himself anything else is pure
frery he's always honest in what he
tells me so I I listened to
him we never had an
argument we
just we just kind of roll with it
easily suppose Warren doesn't want to do
something that I would have done and
suppose that happens four times over 40
years or something what the hell
difference does it make to
me n the record is working out
fine
[Music]
both of us know that we've done better
by having ethics Warren's not interested
in making money by cheating
people Warren's opinions of Wall Street
investment bankers would not endear him
to their mothers he feels that they're
for the most part not out for their
clients they're out for their own
business
interests in the the late 1960s there
were just a flood of accounting
Shenanigans and mergers built upon false
accounting and misleading people it was
a time when a lot of charlatans were
prevailing in Wall Street and were being
applauded by Wall Street and I
understood what the game was about but I
didn't want to play in it so I closed
down the partnership at the end of
1969 and I took on the title of chairman
for the Burkshire
halfway
well I think the modern Berkshire is
pretty much all a reflection of War
on I have constructed a business that
fits
me it's kind of crazy to spend your life
painting if you're painting a subject
you don't want to look at I've gotten to
paint my own painting in business on an
unlimited canvas in a
way it's a different sort of
place I work with great group of people
that make my life very easy and that
take good care of
me we have 25 people in the office and
if you go back it's the exact same 25
the exact same
ones we don't have any committees at
Burkshire we don't have a public
relations department we don't have
Vestor relations we don't have a general
counsel we don't have a human relations
department we just don't go for anything
that people do just as a matter of form
it's exactly the life I
like and it's not work to me it's just a
form of play
[Music]
basically well I like being quiet I shut
the door actually at the office because
I I don't want to hear anybody talking
outside and uh I still probably spend
five or six hours a day reading look at
what's trending today our round what
well what's amazing is the stuff he
remembers it's like a little computer
you know I keep thinking the hard drive
will run out of space but it
doesn't he's one of the smartest people
we know so I was at a couple of the
family dinners at the gates house where
Mary Bill's mom was trying to convince
him to come out to the family place at
Hood Canal to meet Moren Buffett and he
was resisting because he was really busy
with Microsoft and uh finally he said
Mom okay I'll come for
lunch so the two of us flew out there
somewhat reluctantly cuz you know buying
and selling stocks which is how I
thought of Warren uh wasn't a particular
interest to me and didn't seem like
value added it turned out that was
completely wrong we knew that day that
we'd be very close friends in fact we
just couldn't get enough of each
other shortly after I met Bill Gates
Bill's dad asked each of us to write
down on a piece of paper one word that
would best describe what had helped us
the most bill and I without any
collaboration at all least wrote the
word
Focus well Focus has always been a
strong part of my personality if I get
interested in something I get really
interested if I get interested in a new
subject I want to read about it I want
to talk about it and I want to meet
people that are involved in
it we both love to work hard you know
neither of us like frivolous things you
know he doesn't know much about booking
or art or a huge range of
things I can't tell you the color of the
walls in my bedroom or my living room I
don't have a mind that relates to the
physical Universe well
War but uh the business Universe I think
I understand reasonably
well Warren's ability to size up people
and businesses it's a pretty magical
thing he is the best at that of anybody
we know we should all try to be 20% as
as good at
that I like to sit and think and I spent
a lot of time doing that and sometimes
it's pretty unproductive but but I I
find it enjoyable to to think about
particularly about about business or
investment problems they're easy it's
it's the human problems that are the
tough ones sometimes there aren't any
good answers with human problems there's
there's almost a always a good answer
with
money
[Music]
he was s of a
genius I think sometimes Geniuses are by
default lonely and
[Music]
isolated he was not really well
adjusted he was just just funny I mean
humorous guy who maybe had a motor
around him because he was afraid and he
didn't know anyone that he wanted to let
in and to this day I mean I don't
know well nobody knows it like I do and
probably any wife would say that but
uh
he's a loner in a
sense and it's difficult to connect on
an emotional level because I think that
that's not his basic mode of
operation he was there uh physically but
he was upstairs reading all the
time I always told my mother we have to
talk in sound
bites I learned that early on that if
you start you know going into some long
thing unless you've explained to him
ahead of time that it's going to be a
long thing and you need him to hang in
there you lose him you lose him to
whatever giant thought he has in his
head at the time that he was probably
thinking about before you came in and
really wants to get back
[Music]
to he's not like the rest of us I don't
think my dad ever took anybody for
granted but you are a little bit blind I
think sometimes to what other people
might be doing behind the scenes and my
dad's gotten a little bit of a
pass Warren can't find the light switch
and it's probably my fault one time
years ago when the kids were little I
was feeling really sick I had the flu so
I lay down on the bed and I said to
Warren will you get me a pan or
something from the kitchen I may not get
to the bathroom I feel so sick he said
okay so TR down to the kitchen and I
hear this bang boom
bang and he comes up and he brings me a
chander and I looked at it and I said
look honey this has holes in it oh oh
okay so he ran down all the banging he
comes up and he puts the colander on a
cookie
sheet physical proximity waren doesn't
always mean that he's there with
you he's so cerebral you
see and that's why I learned to have my
own life we were two parallel lines and
but very connected when he was open to
[Music]
connecting I did make a joke at one
point I said you know we could make a
take
of Mom yelling you know bye Warren I'll
be back later and then have the door
slam and you would just think she was
here I don't think he knew what she was
doing most of the
time once Howe and I were both gone as
we've gotten older she started to see
the writing on the wall here and you
know just started trying to figure out
how she could at least have some more
she called it you know a room of her
own
the worst mistakes involve not
understanding other people as well uh as
you
[Music]
might well she left Omaha in
1977 and uh there really isn't much to
say about
that
it was devastating for him and I came
home because I I I I can't say I was mad
at her exactly but I kept thinking how
can you leave him he's so he can't
function by
himself so my mother she' asked a bunch
of her friends to sort of look in on him
and OST was one of them I called asard I
said asard will you take one make him
some soup go over there and look after
him because he's not going to make it
and it took him a while to figure it out
but he figured it out I said I'm not
leaving you because I'll be wherever you
want me when you want
me my mom moved to San Francisco and I
think one of the reasons it was
important for her to leave Omaha was
because she just felt like she was kind
of Trapped in this environment that
everybody knew who she was that she you
know couldn't have her own
identity he knew that there's something
she needed to do and that she really
recognized that the money gave us all
and her a choice in a lot of ways that a
lot of people didn't have there was a
time Warren was getting criticized that
here was this very very rich man who was
getting richer every year and really
wasn't giving a lot of money away and
there was terrific criticism by some
people which war never said anything
about the biggest thing in making money
is time you don't have to be
particularly smart you just have to be
patient Susie didn't want to wait as
much as I did but she never quite
appreciated compounding like I
did that is a disagreement we have I run
the foundation
now I think we should be giving more
money away but I understand why we don't
because it's um business to me the Crux
of it is that it wasn't the money itself
you can see that in the way he lives I
mean he doesn't buy huge paintings or
build big houses or anything like that
it's all mental with him and the money
is his scorec
card and he used to say to me everybody
can read what I read it's a Level
Playing Field
and he loves that because he's
competitive and he's sitting there all
by himself in his office reading these
things that everybody else can win but
he loves the idea that he's going to
win I'll tell you how you do it have you
ever seen a juggler juggle 25 milk
bottles how did he ever get to do that
he answered he started with one bottle
and two then three and just kept doing
it and pretty soon he was at 25 and
that's the way we did it so basically we
started out with cash and ended up
buying a bunch of businesses including
insurance
companies insurance is in itself
profitable business but it has the
additional advantage of creating
something that's called float and Float
is the money that hangs around Berkshire
while a claim is waiting to be paid and
War turned out to have a extraordinary
ability to use the money thrown off by
the float to buy companies that fed the
growth of
Berkshire in 1983 Mrs B cashed in on her
business by selling control for $55
million to a company owned by investor
Warren
Buffett Warren was quite an expert about
newspapers he got interested in the post
because he recognized it as a greatly
undervalued
company he had to write me a letter Dear
Mrs Graham I've just bought 5% of your
company and I mean you know harm and I
think it's a great company I know it's
Graham owned and gram run and that's
fine with me and I thought whoa this guy
is really
terrific he used to come to board
meetings with about 20 annual reports
and he would take me through these
annual reports I mean it was like going
to business school with Warren
Buffett K Graham did introduce Warren to
the world of Washington entirely
different group than he had ever dealt
with
before it was clear that working with K
gave him a different kind of confidence
and he was the
star everyone wants to hear what Warren
Buffett has to say the Oracle of Omaha
building his image and having some
fun virture shares have increased more
than 2,000% in value one of the largest
market capitalizations in the world and
it could grow a lot larger since Warren
Buffett shows no sign of slowing down so
how did he do it by investing in what he
knows and understands good oldfashioned
American brands like Coca-Cola Fruit of
the Loom and Dairy Queen what inspired
you I'm this inspired me what you like
is that what yeah
absolutely today the Coca-Cola company
will sell almost 2 billion 8 O servings
of one form or another of Coca-Cola
products now if you get an extra penny a
day a penny of serving that's $20
million a day that's $7.3 billion a year
from one penny
more when you own Coca-Cola you own a
little piece of the minds of billions
and billions of people
that is really
good who's got the most $100 bills these
days well his name is Warren Buffett in
this country and he has just displaced
his friend Bill Gates as the richest
businessman in the
[Music]
world and the purpose of Wednesday's
meeting was to discuss Buffett's company
Berkshire Hathway's plan to purchase
railroad giant Burlington Northern
valued at $26 billion this would be
Buffett's largest acquisition
ever he's created virt from virtually
nothing into hundreds of billions of
dollars of market cap nobody else has a
record like that he wanted to have an
outstanding reputation that he never
really upset the apple cart when he
bought a business that he kept the
management in
place he was establishing a reputation
that paid off later in
life it's been building and building
ever since I've known
[Music]
them it takes 20 years to build a
reputation and it takes 5 minutes to
lose
it when Warren made his investment in
Solomon I was one of the people along
with many many others who were quite
amazed because he had taken a very
critical tone in talking about
investment bankers and about their greed
and here he was investing in one Solomon
Brothers that was known to be a member
of the
club Warren and Charlie went on the
board and Charlie couldn't stand what
was going on there and didn't like the
culture at all and uh shortly after they
got involved the thing
exploded
in
1991 on a terrible day in a I got a call
and the two top officers of Solomon were
on the other end and they said that that
uh you know we had to drop
them this is NBC Nightly News good
evening it is the kind of Scandal that
rocks Wall Street and raises questions
questions about the Integrity of our
financial in
stions with the giant Securities firm of
Solomon Brothers under investigation for
improper trading of Treasury
bonds Solomon admitted it exceeded the
limit of trading in government bonds
once by buying Bonds in the name of a
customer who didn't even know about the
deal Solomon Brothers is under
investigation by the treasury Department
the Federal Reserve the SEC and the
justice department but more important
than the fate of the firm itself is the
impact their actions could have on the
public Trust and on The credibility of
the American Market
worldwide the company owed $150 billion
it Ed more money than any other private
company in the United States at the time
and that night I met with a man that ran
the Federal Reserve of New York who was
the sheriff in effect and I said you
know I've never really owed very much
money before I said I've got a little
mortgage on a house but 150 billion is a
little staggering and I was hoping he
would say well don't worry Warren we'll
give you a few weeks to breathe and he
he said to me prepare for any
[Music]
eventuality earlier today the US
Treasury Department announced that it
had suspended Solomon Brothers from
participating in the auction of new
issues it was one more jolt for Scandal
scarred wall
stre the Fed was in fact saying you're
an evil force and we we don't want you
trading our
bonds it was a huge turning point for
Warren and he believed that at that
particular Point his reputation was on
the
line Warren had 24 hours to make up his
mind as whether he was going to go
forward or just bow out and I think at
that point Solomon Brothers could have
gone into
bankruptcy and Warren stepped up and
took
responsibility
okay at uh I'm Warren Buffett I was uh
elected uh interim chairman of Solomon
Inc uh few hours ago at a board of
directors meeting why was it necessary
for you to step in and what is your
Mandate of leadership I think that it
was necessary to step in because I would
do whatever was needed to dig out any
bit of information about what's happened
in the past and I would do everything I
could to make sure that thing's exactly
right right in the future are you
satisfied I had to convince the treasury
that what was done in the past was awful
and stupid and they had every right to
be furious at us but this firm employed
8,000 people and it was going to go out
of business unless they let us continue
basically Warren believe that there was
a too big to fail scenario the term was
not used then but he believed that
Solomon was too big to fail and if
Solomon went down it would take other
important parts of Wall Street with
it we had this death nail from the
treasury so I called the treasury Nick
Brady was the
secretary you know I'm pleading for my
life and I'm sure my voice was cracking
and everything else I said Nick this is
the most important day of my life and
that I really did feel that it was going
to be a colossal disaster
he wasn't sure I was right at all in
fact he probably thought I was wrong but
he knew that I felt what I was
saying so the treasury modified its
order and in effect of course it was
quite an
endorsement it was
[Music]
huge it saved Solomon Nick Brady went
with Warren because he trusted him it
shows how having a good reputation is
really helpful
life I thank you for the opportunity to
appear before this
subcommittee I would like to start by
apologizing for the acts that have
brought us here the nation has a right
to expect its rules and laws to be
obeyed but I also have asked every
Solomon employee to be his or her own
compliance officer after they first obey
all rules I then want employees to ask
themselves whether they are willing to
have any contemplated act appear appear
the next day on the front page of their
local paper to be read by their spouses
children and
friends if they follow this test they
need not fear my other message to them
lose money for the firm and I will be
understanding lose a shred of reputation
for the firm and I will be ruthless I
welcome your
questions
been 50 years since I formerly took
control of Berkshire halfway and uh step
by step we've created something that is
kind of what I dreamt we might create
over time but it took a lot of time to
do it never seemed like we were making
that much progress on any one day but
compounding interest
works when you think back 50 years ago
when you founded this company did you
ever imagine it would be the fifth
largest company in the world uh no I I
didn't but if I was thinking about it I
wouldn't have thought in terms of being
the fifth or the fourth or the third you
would have woned number one well I mean
if you're going to dream you might as
well
dream
well a Berkshire haway sholders meeting
is partly a fun Festival it's sort of a
marra for people to come every year it's
a chance for us to have a lot of fun and
meet people that have entrusted us with
their
money well we used to have just a 30
people in a
cafeteria and now we have this huge
public
spectacle celebration is part of making
making a group of people work well
together it's a celebration we are glad
you're here at our
meeting be sure to check out our Wares
we'll sell you SE candy and dily bars
and insurance for all of your cars for
it's byy byy byy all you see at the Burk
sure
show
he truly loves to do what he
does I think investors who own burshire
hathway they see themselves as a part of
a
community there are more long-term
holders of Burkshire than any company
people consider it a
religion they don't buy it with the idea
they're going to sell it next week I
think most of them buy it with the
intent of holding it for their lifetime
just like they'd buy a farm or buy an
apartment house at Burkshire everybody
gets the same information from the
comprehensive annual
report we don't meet with the analysts
I'm not interested in what an analyst
thinks about burshire I'm interested in
what the owners of burshire think about
burshire he came out of a priv
partnership where people he knew were
trusting
him and he had his relatives in the
partnership and they were not rich and
as it got bigger started treating
everybody else the way he treated his
relatives in terms of our feeling toward
the people who are shareholders we
regard them as our partners they're not
some faceless group of people and that's
why at the annual meeting you know I
love seeing 40,000 of
them it gives real meaning to what we're
doing every
day let's
[Music]
try we just have a lot of love and
respect for each other and that's never
changed I don't go to most things in
Omaha because I think as lives there
with him and that's for her to
do and then we do all kinds of
things
strange as it may seem to people I
always think you know who cares if it's
working between the people who are
directly involved who cares what anyone
thinks and my mother and a were very
close you know they really really loved
each other and I think that my mother
was glad that she was there because she
you know she loved my dad she wanted him
taken care of and happy and there's no
one better than ostd I mean she loves my
dad she wouldn't care if he had one
cent well asra has lived with me for a
long time she's done wonders for me it
worked well but I don't think it'll work
for lots of other people
necessarily sus and I loved each other
and we admired each other and we were
totally in sync with what the other was
doing but we were two different
individuals the first time waren came
out to San
Francisco we took a walk and he looked
around and he doesn't he's not very
visual
he was looking around and he said this
really is this is your
[Music]
city I am so drawn the color and light
and form and nature that he thought it
was a good place for
me over the years I've developed a
better understanding of human nature I
can learn a lot about Investments out of
a book but I don't think think you can
learn as much about human beings you
really need some experiences and I'm
wiser in that respect than I was 40 or
50 years ago even though I can't rattle
off numbers the same way I used to be
able
[Applause]
to well I think that what we do reflects
who we are that's true for everybody in
this room and if you do the work I do
you meet the best human beings in the
world people who have made a choice not
to make money but to serve other human
beings I think it's the best kind of
Life anyone could have I was with her in
Arizona at this Fortune most powerful
Women's Conference and she told me that
she'd had a biopsy the day before and I
didn't really think much of
it then we got home and the biopsy
results were not good it was stage four
oral
cancer I was on my way to a board
meeting in India and I remember saying
to her you know I'll see you when I get
back and she rarely cried and she just
started crying said no you need to stay
here and you need to come out for the
operation so we were all there and the
day she was going into the surgery that
morning my
dad it's funny he there's some of it he
just can't you know he just can't the
thought of something happening to her
was just for him
you know was just the worst thing that
could
[Music]
happen she knew it was going to be
really difficult she knew the recovery
was going to be brutal so I think that
she had that surgery for
[Music]
others it was quite a big surgery she
couldn't talk she couldn't swallow she
couldn't eat but she came out and I
really was with her for the next four
months or so and my dad came out every
[Music]
weekend and in a few months she was
doing
[Music]
better she and my dad had gone to Cody
Wyoming which they did every year with a
bunch of
friends
and my dad called this was I don't know
8:00 at night or something and he
said something happened to Mom I'm in an
ambulance you need to
come I actually thought something had
happened to my dad I don't know why I
thought that but I I guess I thought you
know my mom had had this recovery it was
successful and why would anything happen
to her
it was
horrible and a total shock you know
she'd been fine she'd been fine they
went off to Cody and she was fine and
they were having dinner and you know she
didn't feel well after dinner and she
had the
stroke we went into the hospital room
and my dad was sitting there he'd been
sitting there all night holding her
hand I was so proud of him because when
it came down to it he knew what he was
supposed to do and he did it which was
nothing so my dad went to sleep and I
sat with her and I just kept putting my
hand on her heart to see if she was
breathing and
um at one point you know I didn't didn't
feel anything so I went out and I got
the nurse and I said um can you come in
here and she said no she's
gone so I have to say one of the worst
moments of my life was waking my dad up
to tell him
that it's a very strange thing love you
can't get rid of
it if you try to give it out you get
more
back
if you try to hang on to it you lose
[Music]
it Susie really put me together she
believed in me she she she put she put
me together and uh well not only turned
out to be the person I turned out to be
but I I would not have I actually
wouldn't have been as successful in
Business Without that uh she made me
more of a whole person
he went dark essentially quiet and
inward for a certain amount of
time you know my dad is a solitary guy
and he had lived essentially a solitary
life in a lot of
ways I think it came down to him
figuring out how he was going to get
through this tunnel and get out the
other
side in my head at the time I thought
God I don't know if he'll ever get out
of
bed but he
[Music]
did welcome
I'm Patty ston cyer the CEO of the Bill
and Melinda Gates Foundation and we
appreciate you coming today especially
since I sent a very vague and very late
notice to ask you to come to a
conversation with Bill and Melinda on
the future of
philanthropy so let's get on with it I
have the pleasure of introducing a good
man whose great decision is going to
change the world Warren
Buffett
a remarkable decision tonight from one
of the richest men in the world Mega
billionaire Warren Buffett says he is
giving away most of his fortune to
charity Buffett has pledged to give away
the bulk of his fortune to the Bill and
Melinda Gates Foundation and giving more
than 15% of his money to Foundation
started by his three children and his
late wife Susan one Global Health
activist called what Buffett did today
one of the most remarkably selfless acts
that history will ever
record that's a better hand than I get
at a birkshire haway
meeting I'd like to thank you for coming
it uh it's a great day for me it's a
great day for my family my wife Susie
and I had planned that whatever I made
uh would go back to society and
originally I thought she would outlive
me and that she'd make the big decision
on it but uh since her death
I had to rethink the best way to get the
money into society and have it used in
the most effective way and I had a uh
solution staring me in the
face it was completely out of the blue I
mean
amazing the largest single gift ever
given was what he gave away that
day I'd like to ask the uh people
representing those various foundations
to come
out for first three letters are easy to
sign I just signed
[Applause]
[Music]
dad when he wrote the letter to us he
put something in that letter that was
incredibly important to me which was
exactly how our foundation behaves which
is if you're going to try to bat a
thousand you won't do very many things
that are important but if you're willing
to basically strike out a few times you
can really change something big I
CCN well I feel trific about the fact
that my three children each run a
separate Foundation that combines their
special interests whether it's Early
Education or whether it's farming in
areas where people's techniques for
using small plots of land could use a
lot of improvement all kinds of ways
vaccines you name it
more powerful than Buffett's gift is the
message he's sending to other wealthy
Americans that those who have the least
in this world should benefit from those
who have the
most in my entire lifetime everything
that I've spent will be quite a bit less
than 1% of everything I make the other
99% plus will go to others because it
has no utility to
me
so it's silly for me to not transfer
that utility to people who can use
it it's doing me no
good I am so proud of what we
do I almost cry at every board meeting
because I just think she would be so
proud and that is my biggest job in my
opinion is to make sure that every penny
gets spent the way she would want it
spent whoever you are in this life you
don't want to think you wasted a lot of
your energy and love and time on
something
useless I always thought I'd marry a
minister a doctor or somebody out doing
some valuable service to human being
and the fact that I marry somebody who
makes just piles of money is really the
antithesis of what I ever thought but I
know what he is and um he
is there's no finer human being in who
he
[Music]
is
the truth is that I'm here in my
position is a matter of luck how you
doing Grandpa hey
Grandpa when I was born in 1930 the odds
were probably 40 to1 against me being
born in the United
States I did win the ovarian Lottery on
that first day and on top of that I was
male put that down as another 50/50 shot
and now the odds are 80 to1 against
being born a male in the United States
and if was enormously important in my
whole life to think that that makes me
Superior in anyone else as a human being
is just I can't follow that line of
reasoning perfect okay good
[Music]
luck I think I was lucky to have been
standing alongside Warren Buffett while
he was becoming Warren Buffett he has
developed over the years he's
broadened his values extend through all
of his life
he wants to lead a life that he and his
father if his father was still living
would say was a good
one I think he's going to end up in the
history books a 100 years from now I'm
not sure what role he's going to be
assigned will he be famous for what he
did as an investor or as a
philanthropist but Warren said that his
ambition in life is to be a
teacher the world is a great movie to
watch but you don't want to sleep walk
through life the important thing to do
is to look for the job you would take if
you didn't need a job and life is
wonderful then I mean you know you you
jump out of bed in the morning because
you're really looking forward to the day
I have for over 60 years been able to
tap dance to work just because I'm doing
what I love doing and and I just feel
very very lucky okay class
dismissed
[Music]
hi do you fear death no I
don't I've had a terrific life I feel
you know it's going to happen and uh I
have no idea what happens after I'm I'm
an di agnostic so I you know it it may
be terribly interesting it may not be
interesting at all we'll find out but
physically I'm pretty well depreciated
I'm getting down to salvage
[Music]
value but it really doesn't make any
difference at all it doesn't interfere
with my work it doesn't interfere with
my happiness it doesn't interfere with
my
thinking I don't feel any demolution
in my enjoyment of life or enthusiasm
for life at all in fact in a sense the
game that I'm in gets more interesting
all the
time it's a competitive game it's a big
game and I enjoyed the game a
lot
[Music]
somewhere over the
rainbow way up
high there's
a land that I heard of once in
a
[Music]
Somewhere Over the Rainbow skies are
blue and the dreams that you dare to
dream really do come
true day I wish upon a star and wake up
where the clouds are far behind find
me where troubles melt like lemon drops
away above the chimney tops that's where
you'll find
me
somewhere over the rainbow blue birds
fly bir birds
fly over the
rainbow why then oh why can't
[Music]
I
somewhere over the rainbow blue bird
fly birds
fly over the
rainbow why that oh why can't
I if happy little bluebirds fly beyond
the
rainbow why oh why
can good night
s